joining us now is ennis cantor freedom
nba player for the boston celtics and
outspoken critic of china's abuses and
it's great to see you tonight
how hard is it
for these athletes to be put into this
situation by basically
the ioc and greedy broadcasters
thanks for having me laura i mean first
of all people need to understand this
and i say this over and over again the
chinese communist party does not
represent the olympic core values of
excellence of respect of friendship the
whole world knows now they're a brutal
dictatorship and they engage in
censorship they threaten freedoms they
do not respect human rights and they
hide the truth
and while we are talking right now
there's a genocide happening
and you know we keep talking about ioc
but the ioc is complicit and echo ccp
propaganda and also you know people need
to understand this you know especially
the athletes they have a huge platform
so i feel like you know i wish one of
them came out and said you know enough
is enough and i am not gone but it is
what it is um like like you said like
everyone said i'm not gonna give one
minute of my time to watch anything
about olympics in the next two weeks
well speaker of the house nancy pelosi
she made a comment about the athletes
watch
i would say to our athletes
you're there to compete
do not risk
incurring the anger of the chinese
government because they are ruthless
i know there is a temptation on the part
of some
to speak out while they are there
i respect that
but i also worry
about what the chinese government might
do
ennis isn't this quite something she
admits
that they could put themselves in danger
by speaking about anything other than
maybe their competition
and yet
we're all supposed to just say isn't
this great that everyone's over in
beijing it's a it it it's a consonant
dissonance it doesn't make any sense
those two points
i mean i actually did uh sort of a video
just uh 30 minutes ago and it broke my
heart because you know athletes i feel
like needs to use their platform to
bring awareness of what's going on
around the world and obviously china
right now is the biggest human right
abuses in the world and so i feel like i
mean to all the athletes my message is
you know while you're there take it one
take it one one or two a day and visit
at the concentration camps if you can
you know see what tibetans or hong kongs
are going through take another trip to
taiwan and see what what democracy means
so when i saw that video it definitely
did
break my heart
and it's a friend of mine is actually
in the official delegation as a
physician
and he told me
that their entire day consists of
going to their
you know residence their hotel whatever
it's called
and then going to the competition or
practice
and then going back
there is no
traveling outside of the the of the you
know of the facilities there's no
sightseeing there's no nothing so there
is no opportunity to talk to chinese
people or
none not nothing that's their experience
in china
propaganda that's that's all i'm uh
saying propaganda and obviously you know
i feel like atleast needs to push it but
i don't
haven't seen any you know brave uh
athlete that came out and said enough
and i'm gonna just make a scene and see
show the whole world that real side of
china but
uh all i'm saying is that china gonna
use this uh as a propaganda
now chinese basketball star um
who you know former nba power player yao
ming
he led the olympic torch relay in
beijing which was shortened due to
coveted restrictions so ns you called
him out
on this
on twitter
what did you say
um but i will say his big body small
heart and tiny brain actually he invited
me over at china
he invited me over china and wanted me
to
visit and i was like okay i mean i was
actually considered and going but he
unfortunately uh
he is the puppet of uh china and
actually just like a little kid he
blocked me on instagram
and
just didn't respond because i wanted to
go visit the concentration camps i
wanted to visit hong kong and tibet and
while when we are done with china i
wanted to take him to taiwan but
obviously uh he was too scared to answer
me but it's just a shame it just shows
one more time that what kind of puppet
he is and what kind of dictatorship that
is happening in in china it just clearly
shows to the whole world
anis have you tried to talk to lebron
james about this issue
and try to
pull him over to the right side on this
uh not really i wish you know not just
him but like you know there are
many nba players and not just you know
in mba but many other associations and
organizations and companies and you know
corporate sponsors i feel like people
need to
wake up and be in the right side of the
history but obviously when it's too much
money involved when it's too much
business involved and also endorsement
these are involved people are scared to
say a word but you know it is what it is
we just i feel like we just need to be
on the right side of the history
and keep these people accountable
and as i want to say
you're speaking out consistently
forthrightly plainly about what this is
it's awesome and i want to thank you
very much for doing that
thank you for being with us hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else